"I found you."
Are you ready? Did you sleep well?
Well, yeah.
What?
I was just speaking poorly of you
with Rouis.
So peaceful, huh?
You are acting even more strange today.
Bill.
You...
I gotta go to the bathroom!
I'll be right back.
Hey, we have only ten minutes!
Gosh, you followed me to the bathroom.
You must really be into me.
What are you...
hiding under the costume?
So, I was not able to fool the keen
olfactory sense of a canine after all.
Or what? You want a sip?
-That's...
-Rabbit's blood.
Of course, this is not
from one of the students.
Just one of the older punks gave it to me.
I've kept it, just in case.
Well, today is the "case," you know?
So, I really had no choice this time--
Hey, listen to me now.
It should be easier to live in the shadow
like you.
But I want to live in the light!
So, this is a reasonable doping!
You always suck up to herbivores!
You just keep dodging responsibilities.
You would never understand me!
He is right...
I can't talk back to him.
Why don't you take responsibility
for your strength?
I don't want to run away anymore.